[MUSIC PLAYING]
STEVE COLE: Well, good
morning, everybody.
Thank you for coming
to the session today.
I'm looking out around
the room and thinking
there should probably be a
Google Next endurance award
for folks that are here.
So we're day three.
If you were at the
Partner Summit,
this is day four for you.
So again, credit for being here.
If you were at The
Chainsmokers last night,
you get extra credit.
Anyway.
So I think-- I hope you share
with me the thought that this
has been a great conference.
And I'm going to share
a little bit with you
today about what we're doing.
And may even wave around
marketing analytics.
And that's about driving
the right message
to the right customer
for the right product
at the right time.
If you are not familiar
with Maven Wave,
we're a technology
consulting company.
We deliver rapid solutions
to complex problems
for large companies.
We work almost exclusively
on the Google Cloud Platform.
We've been a partner
of Google since 2010.
We're a Premier Partner for data
analytics and machine learning.
And we were very honored to
receive the North America
Services Partner of
the Year Award for 2017
earlier this week.
So that's who we are.
What I'm hoping you'll learn
from my session in the next 45
minutes or so, is first of
all, why is market analytics
important?
Why is this something that
you should be focused on?
Second, I'll share
a framework with you
that we're using in working
with our clients to deliver
marketing analytics solutions.
And third, we'll
map that framework
to a number of
hexagons that represent
what we're doing-- how we're
engaging the Google Cloud
Platform to deliver
for our customers.
Before we get into
a lot of slideware,
I thought I'd tell
you a quick story.
And that quick story
is about this company
that we have developed
called Salient Auto.
Salient Auto is an
automotive manufacturer
based in our home office
in Chicago, Illinois.
If you'd like one, stop by
our booth in Moscone South.
It's about this long.
But we have plenty to give
away, so stop by later on
and grab one from us.
But the point of
this is that I wanted
to actually start
this conversation
with the demonstration, rather
than traditionally leaving
the demo to the
end, and show you
what we've been doing around
marketing analytics for Salient
Auto.
And this is
essentially what I'll
talk about in the
framework in a few minutes.
But the way that we start this
is by aggregating together
a lot of information about the
customer and the customer's
journey into BigQuery.
We're using this as a--
BigQuery, essentially,
is the aggregation point
for data about marketing
and data about the customer.
And we're using that
to drive dashboards.
So we're looking at this from
the perspective of a marketing
manager at an
automotive dealership.
We're creating a
dashboard for him
that lets him see exactly how
his marketing is performing
within his dealership.
And as you can see,
we've got a number
of tiles that represent
different parts all
of his marketing mix.
A couple of things
that I'll point out
to you, because this is not just
a traditional backward-looking
dashboard.
We're also incorporating
recommendations in here.
A couple of things
that we're highlighting
in red-- first of
all, he has a budget
for incentives that are
driven from Salient Corporate.
So there's a regional
incentive plan
and this dealership has
$50,000 in the current quarter
they can distribute
across different vehicles
as additional incentives
to their customers
to buy a specific product.
And we're also going
to see in a minute
that there are recommendations
that we're making around--
well, the machine
learning algorithm
is making around recommending
specific keywords
that they should be purchasing
for the coming week.
Most likely since we've
made some recommendations
about adjusting keywords,
actually changing some budget--
I don't know if you can
read this in the back,
but the recommendation
says we should
optimize the budget by moving
some money from TV to keywords.
And also recommending that we
should update some incentives,
so deploying incentives
against specific vehicles.
And the vehicles that
we'll see in a minute,
as it's highlighted
in red over here--
there are three vehicles
on this dealer's lot
that are over 60 days old.
And if you've spent any
time working in automotive,
you know that after
60 days, that's
when the manufacturer stops
paying for the inventory,
and you, as a dealer, have
to start paying for it.
So it's kind of
critical for the dealer
to move that inventory
as soon as possible.
So our marketing
manager maybe will
drill down into a budget
planner and look at this
in a little bit more detail.
You can see some of the
same recommendations
on this top panel, here,
but as we drill in--
here's his dealership
performance
against his peers, the circle
being average across the peer
dealers in his region.
And he can see, he's
overperforming at the moment,
on TV, and underperforming
on key words.
And that's part of
the recommendation
that we're going to be using.
Now, in the bottom,
here, you can
see the smart incentives that--
that smart incentives fund
that's been available to them.
I actually think we're
doing a pretty good job
because we have a 75%
win rate where we're
deploying smart incentives.
That's a good thing.
So because our fictitious
marketing manager is not
a very trusting person,
we could, of course,
automate this next
step, but I'll
show you the detail behind it.
So what are the keywords
that we're recommending?
So there's a model in the
Salient line called a Haraka.
And the recommendation is
that we go ahead and purchase
the key word silvia Salient--
sil-- this is very
difficult to say.
Silver Salient Haraka.
And bid-- I'm going to
kill someone in creative
that did that, by the way.
I think they-- they
ambush me every time.
Silver Salient Haraka.
And have it set a
daily budget of $23.33.
So there's some rationale down
here about why that's the case.
I'm not going to go into
that great detail today.
But we'll go ahead and
just set the keywords.
So if I click set
keywords, there, it's
going to take me back
to my prior screen.
And I'll update the budget.
And that's going to move
the money in my budget
from TV into keywords.
Then, if I flip ahead
to my AdWords page,
you'll notice there's nothing
down at the bottom of the page,
right now.
But if I hit refresh, if the
demo gods are on our side,
it will have gone ahead and
populated that ad for us.
Not yet.
We'll hit refresh again.
Somebody sing the
"Jeopardy" theme for me.
Still not showing up.
One more time.
OK.
Well, we'll leave it at that.
So demos have some problems.
What we're doing actually
is recalling the AdWords API
in the background.
We're injecting the specific
ad with a specific budget
against it.
And we're linking it
directly to the page
for the individual car.
Try this one more time.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
[LAUGHTER]
STEVE COLE: I'd say we've
managed to do this without,
but I'll just let it go.
So we're targeting
then the specific car.
And that allows us to
move buyers specifically
to that page from the
purchase-- anyway.
So we were 95% complete
on the demo, today.
It's a little less than
I would usually expect.
OK.
So that's a way of
thinking about some
of the steps that
we'll talk about later,
in terms of how we're
going about doing marketing
analytics.
Build a warehouse
of data, move--
create a visualization,
create some analytics
around that data, and
then activate on that.
So moving on from there.
Then, I think the
question, though, that--
when I'm talking to clients,
what they're really asking is,
why should marketing analytics
be a priority for my business?
I'm going to propose
that there are
two things that are critically
important to you, here.
One is the performance
of your business.
And the second one is that
your customers are radically
changing.
So let's look at
first one first--
performance of your business.
So Forrester did
a report in 2016
where they looked across
businesses at performance
of the marketing function.
And what they
found was companies
that have an integrated-- a
well-integrated marketing,
data, and tools
environment, really
are outperforming their peers.
And they are outperforming
their peers roughly
by beating their budgets
each year by over 10%,
or their revenue
goals by over 10%.
So that's a fairly
significant marker
for leading organizations.
They also recognized that 35%
of the marketers they talked to
saw Return On Marketing
Investment, or ROMI,
as being one of the
most valuable metrics
that they had to secure
additional budgets
for their marketing programs.
However, almost all the folks
that Forrester talked to
found that most
of these marketers
didn't have a way of
actually measuring return
on marketing investment.
And so clearly what
comes from that is really
a call for what we
were talking about
earlier, this idea of
an integrated data set,
an integrated data
warehouse that
really spans across the
entire marketing function.
Another way of looking at this--
McKinsey, 2017, asked
business leaders
across functions and
across industries,
how is big data and analytics
affecting your business?
You, perhaps, would
expect that the sectors
on the right-hand side of
this chart, high tech, energy,
and sectors like that are
impacted fairly substantially
by big data and analytics.
What was really notable
to me, and, perhaps,
why I have this chart here,
is that sales and marketing
across industries was
noted by business leaders
as being heavily impacted
by big data and analytics.
And so again, this
is another reason
why we see leading companies
now turning attention
to marketing data and
marketing analytics
because it is transformational
for their businesses.
Second thing, then--
your customers.
And the way that
I experience this
is probably the same
way that you do.
I would ask you to just
reflect on the journey
that you had-- the
physical journey you
had planning and getting to
Next over the past few days.
How many humans did you
interact with in that process?
I'll propose to you that number
is very, very small-- maybe
the person who checked
you in at the hotel.
But most likely almost
all of your interactions
were done without
human intervention.
And we're expecting and
research is showing us
that by 2020, 85% or more
of relationships between us,
as customers, and companies
is going to be done
without any human interaction.
And that puts a
tremendous burden on us
as marketers to really
understand our customers.
And of course, we have the
same complementary issues
or opportunities being
presented to us around the move
from desktop to mobile.
We have customers' expectations.
And I'm a customer.
My expectations of the people I
work with are very, very high.
I expect them to know me.
And so that change in the
way customers are behaving
is another driver behind this
need for integrated analytics
around marketing.
And this is really because
our journeys have become
much more complex as customers.
We're self-directed now.
Back not that long ago,
marketers would essentially
be able to tell you how you
should experience their brand.
That has completely been
flipped on its head, now.
We, as consumers-- and I'm
putting myself in your place--
as a consumer, I'm deciding how
I experience your brand now.
What order I ask
questions, what devices I
use, where I am
physically, whether I'm
using online or offline
contact with you--
all of that is completely
changing the way
that the customer
experience is occurring.
Again, that drives
the need for us
to have a new way
of understanding
how that relationship works.
What the customer
journey really is.
And just to compound
it, or maybe it's
all a part of the same
thing, we're more demanding.
We expect marketers--
we expect the brands
that we work with
to understand us,
to be able to create this
seamless experience based
on intimate knowledge about
who we are and what we want.
And that means that we have to
really get to information that
is relevant and timely and
immediate for each interaction
that we have with a customer.
So our responses
have to be tailored.
They have to be immediate.
They have to meet our needs
for a short attention span.
They have to be shareable.
They have to be memorable.
They have to be completely
relevant to your point of view
or your point in the journey
with that brand, at that time.
So that takes us to,
how do we do this?
So the second thing I wanted
to talk about today, as I said
at the outset was talk about a
framework on how we relate to
or how we talk to
our customers and how
we're implementing these
types of solutions for them.
So we have a fairly simple
marketing analytics framework.
It consists of three pieces.
And I'll go through
each of them in turn.
Building a comprehensive
marketing data warehouse.
Second, developing
analytics and visualization.
And third then driving on
top of that, machine learning
solutions.
First things first, let's
talk about the framework.
Well, I'll put this in the
context of-- or excuse me.
Not the framework, but
the data warehouse.
Let's put this in the
context of a customer.
Here's a customer.
She's on the phone with
your contact center.
Well, for you to serve her
and to meet her expectations,
you need to know who she is.
You need to know
about her journey.
You need to know what
her expectations are.
What is she expecting to
get out of this conversation
that she's having with you?
Oh, and oh, by the
way, you probably
also, in this interaction, want
to know what your objectives
are, as a marketer.
What do you expect--
what do you want
her to experience?
And how do you want to influence
the journey that she's on?
And so to be able
to do that, we have
to have this kind of
comprehensive knowledge
of her experience so far.
There are a lot of
data sources that we
need to bring to bear here.
And I, in my prior
life as a CMO,
I experienced the same
challenge that I've
talked about with many
marketers here this week.
And that is that we have most
likely in our offices anywhere
between a dozen and
two or three dozen
different marketing
technology applications
that we use to do our jobs.
And they are often
software as a service.
They're tailored towards
specific parts of the marketing
process.
They have their own
individual data silos.
Some of the very
large organizations,
like Salesforce--
some of them are custom,
maybe a warranty system
or a service system for
the automotive industry.
There are a lot of
third parties involved.
Oh, and oh, yes,
of course, there's
also a fair amount
of information
that we can get from
our partners at Google.
So Google Ads and the
Google Marketing Platform--
we can bring all that data
in through the BigQuery data
transfer service.
All of that becomes available
to us fairly quickly.
But we also are writing
or using third parties
to integrate a number of--
all these other systems
into this one holistic
view of the customer.
So we have to be able
to access all that data.
There is some quality
control we have to do.
But we are getting
to the point where
we can look across
devices to get that one
view of the customer--
their journey,
both online and offline.
And I think it's
important to note here
that our goal in
building this is
to look towards the ultimate
outcome for that customer.
So what happened at the end?
Did they buy?
Did they not buy?
Did they-- what is
our lifetime value,
either present or expected,
for that customer?
So we're going beyond just, now,
did I acquire that customer?
Did they click onto my ad?
I want to go all
the way to, what
is the value of that customer?
And what's the value--
how did that customer
experience the journey?
And what do we learn from that?
So there's a lot of data that
needs to be brought together.
We've been doing this for AAA.
They came to us a couple of
years ago, now, and said, gee,
we have a problem.
And our problem is that we
have all these customers
and we have all
these business lines,
but we can't tell
what this customer is
doing across business lines.
So can you help us with this?
And yes, we put together what
we describe as a modern data
platform.
It's essentially that
marketing data warehouse
that I talked about
earlier, bringing data
from across the enterprise,
from across their marketing
applications, and from all
of their internal functions
to create that one
view of the customer.
They've been using that for
a number of applications
from a marketing point of view.
They've been using it to
do better targeting around
their marketing.
So they're communicating
more effectively
and more consistently
with their customers.
And their customers are
hearing from them messages
that are much more relevant.
They're also able to deliver a
much more consistent customer
experience and customer service.
So if you call for
roadside service now,
they know everything about you.
They know more than just
your car needs serviced.
They know whether you are
insured by them, whether you
are a travel customer.
This may not be critical to you
when you've got a flat tire,
but the point being that
they have this holistic view,
and they can use that to create
much more seamless interactions
between themselves
and their customers.
So second piece-- the
analytics and visualization.
And this is where
things get obviously
a little bit more custom.
If you're an automotive
manufacturer,
you're looking
for certain things
from the analytics for
your customer's journey,
obviously, that
experience is somewhat
different from if you're
selling soap powder,
for example, laundry detergent.
But we do have some
templates that we start
from in those conversations.
And these are all
driven around, again,
what the marketers needs are.
"OnBrand Magazine" did a
survey at the beginning of 2018
and asked what brand marketers
priorities were for 2018.
You'll notice that three of the
top four bars on this chart,
so vast majority of folks,
are concerned about something
about the customer experience.
This, again, drives this
issue that we have to--
we really have to
understand what
the customer is experiencing and
how to improve that experience.
And so the analytics
that we're building,
the visualizations that we're
building are really around
helping them understand
that customer experience--
how to acquire
customers effectively,
how to retain them--
so minimizing churn if you
have a long-term business,
long-term relationship--
and how to enhance that
customer experience.
At Crate and Barrel
over the last--
I think this was maybe a
year and a half ago now.
They came to us
with a problem that
was kind of reflective of this
analytics and visualization
problem, which was many of
their internal processes were
difficult. They
were very manual.
They, again, were not able to
bring a visualization together
or bring analytics together that
were helpful to their marketing
team.
And they weren't able to make
decisions in a timely way.
So we developed a set
of dashboards for them.
We automated a lot
of the reporting.
And we've reduced all their
routine reporting by maybe 10x.
And we're delivering much
better, much improved
timed insight for them.
They turned this into money
by identifying a real mismatch
between the time that they
were sending paper catalogs
through the mail, which are very
expensive, to their customers.
And there was a
regional distribution
or a regional demand issue
that they hadn't seen before.
They were able to time
these campaigns differently
and both reduce their costs
and improve response times
by delivering the right
catalog to the right customers
in the right region
at the right time.
The last piece
I'll talk about is
the machine learning solutions.
And here, you can go in a
number of different directions.
As you might expect, I
have a different chart
which I use sometimes, which is
kind of a checkerboard of here
are about a dozen
different sample
machine learning solutions.
You saw a couple earlier
in the demonstration
where we're targeting, what are
the right keywords to select
and what is the right bid
level for a specific vehicle?
And how do we select
the right incentives
to go onto vehicles that have
been on the lot a long time?
A couple of other
samples for you--
customer segmentation
based on this holistic view
becomes much more empowered.
We're talking, now,
about being able to--
if it's a segment based on
specific behaviors in close
to real time, if not
actual real time--
so we're able to really create
much more meaningful segments
being able to address
specific offers to segments
on a much more fine
tuned basis because
of our more holistic view.
The second thing
that we're doing,
which, again, has been difficult
for marketers to do in the past
is to really understand
attribution, which is now
that we're looking at a complete
data set, which spans all
the way from your first contact
with a brand, all the way
through purchase or
nonpurchase, we're
able to use machine learning
techniques to understand
the value of each
marketing channel.
So that allows us
now to say that,
in this particular context,
for this segment of customers,
digital is more
valuable than email,
or digital is more valuable
than search, or vice versa.
The impact of that is
pretty significant.
We take that with our
customers all the way
through optimization and
into marketing mix modeling,
so you can now
reshape your budgets
based on a complete
understanding of what
the actual sales impact
is of the investments
that you've made in each
individual customer's journey.
Going back to our friend
on the phone earlier,
that means that we can
go to her and, knowing
what we do know now
about her journey,
we can take that
next best action.
We can target the offer
to her, in this case,
through the contact center
script that she's using,
or that she's being exposed
to to get her on her journey
to a place where she
has the best customer
experience that she can get from
you, while at the same time,
you're managing her
towards the outcomes that
are most profitable for you.
So we activate a lot of
these machine learning models
through these
different channels.
And of course, this varies
customer by customer,
or client by client,
that we're working with,
but activation now
is really something.
And machine learning driven
activation is something.
It is a reality.
It really is allowing
us, at this point,
to target individually
right product,
right offer, right customer,
right time, right channel.
I would love to stand
here and say that we
can do all this overnight.
Clearly, we can't.
And the way that we approach
this with our customers
is to think of this
in an agile way.
We develop softwares in
other parts of our business
for our clients.
And we use agile as our
core methodology there.
And while it may be a--
while you may not
expect it, this
translates directly into what
we're doing for marketers.
It does because
we're essentially
following an iterative process
in delivering solutions
to them.
We think about it in
these five phases.
And we would tend to go around
the circle multiple times
for an engagement.
So first of all, collecting
and transforming data.
So collecting, as
I said earlier,
we have a whole host of
different source applications
that we're drawing data
from, transforming that data,
and making it available
in the data warehouse.
Analyzing and
visualizing that data.
So analysis is great,
but it's not useful
unless you can actually see it
and have folks make decisions
on it.
So analyze and visualize.
And then activate that
through the marketing channels
that I said earlier.
So actually connecting
back, generally through APIs
to those delivery systems.
So you're delivering
the right message
to the right
customer, right time.
We go through this
cycle multiple times.
It's important that you not
get stuck at any one point.
I encourage you, if you're
going down this path,
to think about use cases first.
What's the data that drives
the use case that drives value?
Go around the cycle.
Get some return on investment.
Show leadership that this is
essentially paying for itself.
That's going to
secure the investment
to do the next iteration
and the one after that.
And that's the
way that I've been
doing this for quite some time.
And we're able to move
forward with these projects
pretty rapidly and at
the same time, show
return to the business.
And there's nothing like
showing a monetary return
on this investment to secure
investment for the next cycle.
So that's the journey.
And I would encourage you to
think about it as a journey.
So you can map those phases
to the Cloud Platform products
that we're using.
As you would expect,
BigQuery is the home,
and as I've described
earlier, BigQuery
is the home for the data
warehouses that we build.
We use other tools from the
GCP suite to ingest data,
whether it's streaming
or batch from all
these different applications.
For analytics, we use Datalab.
We use the Cloud ML
Engine to do analytics
based on what's in BigQuery.
Of course, many of
the ML capabilities
are now merging into
BigQuery, so a lot of this
is going to end up probably
in that one hexagon.
But we've been using a number
of these tools in the past
to get us to this point.
For visualization,
Data Studio is
ramping up faster and faster.
We're getting a lot of
traction now and using
Data Studio with our clients.
We do use partner products.
And I think my colleagues
on the Google side
recognize that clients
have investments
in Tableau and in Looker.
And so as a services
organization,
we certainly work with
those solutions, too,
to deliver the visualizations
they're looking for.
And then, in activation, this
is where we're publishing--
we can publish solutions
from the machine learning
that we're doing as APIs.
And they can be
consumed that way.
Some of the marketing
technologies that we work with
are still batch oriented
and some of the data
is not so volatile that
you need to have an API,
so you can deliver
through batch, as well.
And then that's
essentially the way
we're delivering and activating
to each of these technologies.
So that gives you a sense of the
scope of how we're delivering
and how our customers are
integrating their marketing
analytics or delivering
their marketing analytics,
using the Google Cloud Platform.
So hopefully, that gives you an
idea of how we, as Maven Wave,
are working with the
Google Cloud Platform
to deliver against the goals
of marketing analytics.
You know, as a
former CMO, I wish
I had had this a few years ago.
I think it is really game
changing for the clients
that we're working with.
And I'll just leave
you in summary
with these three thoughts.
First of all, really this
integrated marketing analytics
is a marker, now, of
high performing marketing
organizations.
And the leading enterprises
that we're working with
recognize this is game
changing for them.
If you think back to
that McKinsey chart
that I showed earlier,
analytics and big data
are transformational
for sales and marketing
across all industries.
It's not a one size
fits all solution,
but it's
transformational for all.
And so this is really a
marker of the companies
that are going to be
leading in their industries.
A comprehensive
marketing data warehouse
is essential foundation.
It doesn't all get
built in one day,
but it is really
the foundation, both
for doing analytics
and visualization
and then getting to
machine learning.
So the machine learning
is going to deliver
the insights and
actions that are going
to delight your customers.
And at the end of the day,
it's all about the customer
experience and
delighting that customer.
Last, and most importantly,
is this is a journey.
This is not something that
is going to happen overnight.
But if you start now, you will
be ahead of your competitors.
Go back and look at
that five circle chart,
and start with collecting
that essential data
for that first use case.
Deliver some value, and
you'll be ahead of the curve,
I think, on your analytics,
your marketing environment
versus those of
your competitors.
So that's all I had to
say on this, this morning.
I'd be happy to
answer questions.
I hope you found this valuable.
I know there's only a
couple of hours left,
but if you'd like to talk
further, I'll be at our booth
in Moscone South for the
rest of the afternoon.
So have a great rest of the day.
And thank you for being here.
I appreciate it.
[MUSIC PLAYING]